That day also uh is when a blood moon
will appear and Freemasons who control
America's national security apparatus
rever the number 33 and it goes on from
there. It just feels like at some point
that paragraph shifted into like wait
what why are we talking about the
Freemasons now? So where does that come
from?
>> I completely sympathize and a year ago I
would have I I would have completely um
agreed with you that this is all just
silly conspiracy. So, um, I've been on
the on the on the Birthright trip. Um,
so I'm not Jewish, as you can tell, but
I've been to on the Birthright trip. I I
spent a week in Israel. And, um, you
know, for me, unless you look at this
esquetology, it's almost impossible to
understand why this war in the Middle
East, Middle East, is happening. So,
just to be frank, when I when I told my
audience that you were going to come on,
many people were like, "Oh, don't talk
to that guy, right? He's he's super
dangerous." Um and and they sent me
clips which I'm going to ask you about
of like oh he's a Holocaust denier and
all this kind of stuff and I want you to
clarify them.
>> Um I said listen um I'm not saying the
Holocaust didn't happen. It must have
happened but there's no direct evidence
for it that I could find which I found
really frustrating. Okay. So so that's a
background to what happened.
>> Yeah. Um, I I think that's still going
to not leave people satisfied because I,
you know, they're I'll tell you from
again my per my perspective, the the
mythology kind of always outruns the
truth and that leads to people then
questioning if the truth is the truth at
all.
>> And I think like like the truth um is
value in itself. I think it's your
individual responsibility to seek the
truth. Whether or not you choose to
broadcast this or not um is up to you.
>> How does all of this kind of knowledge
help you or do you think it helps you
make predictions about the general
trends of of the world? You know,
leaning on the Illuminati and all of
these kinds of things. I mean, how how I
guess I guess I'm still a little stuck
on the secret societies. Like how real
>> do you think that is? or are you using
it as sort of just a predictive tool? I
just need to know that Lummit Podcast J
Shapiro here. I won't keep you long on
the intro, but you might be interested
in some of the the caveats and and
pre-tory to this conversation because uh
my guest today is someone you've
probably seen unless you don't use the
internet very much. Uh known as
Professor Xiang online. Um he is quite
the controversial figure. In fact, when
I announced that I was going to have him
on, many people reached out saying what
a bad idea it was that it's not serious.
I should look into him more, etc. Uh,
and I took all that very seriously. Um,
and I do, um, challenge him on many of
these things. But I was thrilled with
the way this conversation went.
Actually, I have to admit I was quite
skeptical myself going in of how it
would turn out. And I thought it was
fantastic. Um, see what you think. it
kind of speaks for itself, but we cover
a lot of interesting ground. And I I
leave the conversation and it's almost a
pseudo debate or more sort of a a mutual
exploration of uh controversial ideas or
complex ideas. And we certainly share or
have uh some similar temperaments about
how to approach questions, definitely
some different language or temperaments
to entertain certain ideas. Uh, but all
in all, I think it was amazingly
fruitful. And I also learned a lot about
him, the man, the man behind the
Professor Xiang avatar that we've all
come to know. Um, and who he is and a
little bit of his background, which I
think really uh matters, stuff that I
didn't know before, and you might not
know either. Uh, and you know, the
internet's a really weird place. I have
no idea why he's gotten so popular. Uh,
we come up with some ideas at the end
for this, uh, of why that may have
happened. It must be very dizzying for
him. Um, it's a very competitive place
on the internet sometimes and I don't
think it's always the best um our best
selves in this like ultra competitive
weird antagonistic state. Uh, and so I
went in with an open mind of of open
push back and common conversation. He
asked me a lot of questions. In fact,
when he reached out, he said he had a
lot of questions about Judaism that he
wanted to ask. Uh, and I did my best
answering what I could. And also, I'll
be back at the end of this video. I'm
sure you could see the kind of bloated
time uh time stamp that we have already.
But if you're willing to give me some
time today, I think you'll get a lot out
of it. I'll be back at the end with some
of my afterthoughts on the conversation,
what I think of of the phenomenon of
Professor Xiang. Um and also to sort of
pick up a thread that you'll hear that I
loosen a little bit throughout the
conversation uh on the Dead Sea Scrolls
that I think is uh really interesting
and important. So meet me at the end if
you're really interested in some of my
afterthoughts. I kept notes during the
uh conversation just to to pick up a few
things and uh yeah now uh enjoy the
conversation with myself and and the man
behind the phenomena of Professor Xiang.
Enjoy.
>> Thanks so much for doing this. This is
this is cool. So yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so yeah.
>> Sorry. Yeah. I I mean like I'm just
looking forward to picking your brain
about certain issues that have been
bothering me. But yeah. Yeah. We we'll
start.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, absolutely. Yeah. I
would love for it to be a bit of a
conversation. I have a feeling we assess
the world in slightly different ways,
but I am I am totally open. Yeah. But
but first I would like to know a little
bit about you cuz probably like most
people you know I I didn't know you
existed until recently and
>> suddenly you you're all over the
internet and you know millions and
millions of views and and it's a very
strange phenomena. Um so so who who are
you? Can you give me a little just a bit
about where you were born, where you
were from, how you got interested in
these questions and where you are now?
Yeah. So my background is um I was born
in 1976 in a village in South China. My
family um was very poor. My dad was a
high school teacher. And because he had
experience of cultural revolution, he
wanted an escape. So we went to Canada.
Uh and my dad worked as a dishwasher and
he's been a dishwasher all his life.
He's he's retired now.
>> Uh but he had a very hard life in
Canada. And uh we went over when I was
six and um I was bullied a lot because I
had a speech impediment. I stuttered a
lot.
>> Um and the language was bewildering to
me. So I didn't do very well in school.
Um and I was a very um lonely child
>> and it was for me very awkward
to grow up as an immigrant in Toronto. I
had a very hard time growing up because
my dad was um he experienced a lot of
racism at work
>> and he was pretty violent and angry at
home.
>> And so I had a very violent uh and
traumatic upbringing
>> and I wanted out of my home. I wanted
out of Canada. And uh so when I was in
high school, I set my set my sights on
the Ivy League uh because they offered a
full scholarship and it was just out of
Canada. I really didn't know much about
them. Um, and I read a lot of books and
um, apparently you have to have like
certain skills in order to um, get in
the Ivy League. For example, you have to
be an athlete. You had you had to have
like leadership skills. You had to be a
charismatic. And I was none of those. I
mean, like I was just like this um um,
stupid immigrant kid with a lot of um,
you know, psychological issues. And so I
set myself um I sort of redesigned
myself in order to fit this like Ivy
League um you know package. And so I
joined the soccer team because because
like they took anyone. Um I start my own
club because no other club would let me
in.
>> Um and I started to do well in school
because actually you know in Canada I'm
like everyone's stupid so you don't have
to do well in school. So you don't have
to be that smart to do well in school.
We have five years of high school rather
than four because we're we're pretty
slow up there. Um but but you know I I
applied to the Ivy League schools and I
got lucky and I got to Yale because like
no one wants to go to New Haven. I'm not
sure if you've been to New Haven but
like no one
>> Yeah. Um, so, so it was the only Ivy
League school that took me and I went to
Yale and I was hoping to flourish as a
person, hoping to meet people who were
like me, who were like intellectually
curious, um, who were very open-minded,
who who had a passion for learning. And
>> that was not Yale. Uh, EL was very much
a school focus focused on success, on
achievement,
>> you know, on um on getting to law
school, going to Wall Street, making a
lot of money. And so, I didn't really
fit into Yale either. And so, I started
to search my my cultural roots. I
started to learn Mandarin, Chinese,
>> and um I started to think about going
back to China. And I and so after I
gradu from Yale, I I came I came I came
to China and I've been there ever since.
So it's it's almost like it's over 25
years. It's almost like 30 years now. I
came in 99
and um I wanted to
promote education reform in China
because
>> I mean I was a depressed child. I I I
was suicidal at times. I was bullied a
lot and education really transformed me.
I really believe in the power of
reading, the power of critical thinking
in order to transform lives. I've been
trying very hard to uh um promote it. It
didn't really work out. And um a couple
years ago, I started to get into
geopolitics and I started to make videos
about my geopolitical predictions.
And um it was just a thought experiment.
It was it was just a silly experiment to
see how if it was possible to predict
the future just because growing up I was
a huge fan of Isaac Azimov. Um and I
love the Foundation series. And so so
that always stuck with me and I I and I
I was asking myself are there certain
patterns to history um and if there are
patterns then how can we uh decipher uh
these patterns. So, I started to make
these videos um about the United States
invading Iran,
>> uh about American Civil War breaking
out, about Trump winning uh in 2024.
And uh here we are, you know. So, um I
was expecting about like 5,000 like
subscribers. My my ambition was 5,000
subscribers and um yeah, now I'm world
famous and everyone hates me. So, so
>> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're getting bullied
again in a different way. And I don't
and I and I don't want to echo that, but
but it's interesting. You caught a wave
certainly.
>> Um, and then ju just to set the record
straight because it does annoy people.
Your your your title on YouTube of
Professor Xiang. You're not technically
a professor. You're a high school
student or teacher, excuse me. And these
are recordings of your high school
class. Just a sec that record.
>> So, let's let's set the record straight.
Okay. Um, I have a BA in English
literature from Yale College. And that
is it. that is the extent of my uh
schooling and I've worked in the in the
high school for the past four years
teaching the great books. So Homer and
Dante and Plato
>> and um at first I was just uploading my
high school classes. But once I became
popular about a year ago, people started
to refer to me as Professor Dang. And
that was a lot better than me
pronouncing my my full name, which is
Janguin. So I said, "Let's just go with
Professor J because it's the internet
and no one cares." You know, there's
this guy who calls himself God and no
one seems to mind.
>> So I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So So, so I um so I started to
pick up this moniker, Professor Dang.
And you know, you know, I mean, like
like and you know um ever since then
people have been making comments that
I'm not a full professor. I don't have a
PhD. I'm not accredited at a university.
And it's all true, but but my um viewers
are like it doesn't really matter. It's
just our resp our respect uh to him.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And personally, I don't
care. I think there's a there's a a
credentialism that's ridiculous in the
intellectual game. I mean, I I have a
book coming out on philosophy, but I
don't have a PhD in philosophy. So, my
call philosopher like it's it's all a
bit silly. So, okay, to set that aside,
though. Um but but yeah, so
I would love to start with you. people,
you know, are starting to call you this,
you know, political prophet in these
ridiculous I I think ridiculous kind of
of terms about the new Nostradamus and
all this kind of stuff. Predicting the
future is really really hard. Predicting
politics is really really hard. Maybe
you get right sometimes. I I you know,
but we all do it in the in you know,
with our friends over dinner tables and
in chat groups or whatever. I could give
one of mine. When Donald Trump won in
2016, I made a prediction that before
the end of his term, he would make a
motion to uh leave the UN, to have the
United States revoke its membership to
the UN. It didn't happen in the first
term. Maybe it happens in the second
term. But would I say, oh, he made the
board of peace, so I was kind of right.
Like, you know, these things are a
little silly. But so, how would you
assess your your own accuracy of your
predictions generally? How do you give
yourself an assessment of that? How how
good are you at at that?
>> Yeah. So, I think I'm pretty good at
broad trends about the general direction
of the world. Um, and I'm very bad at
specifics and timeline, right? So, for
example, um, I thought that Trump would
pick Nikki Haley as his VP instead of G
bands.
>> Um, I also expected the war start maybe
in 2027. Um, because you you need you
need about a year like staging
operation. um you you want to like
actually plan and do logistics and they
didn't do that. So when it comes to like
timeline and when it comes to spec
specifics I'm not very good but when it
comes like broad contours
>> of general geopolitical movements then
um then I I'm very good.
>> Yeah. Okay. All right. Fair enough.
Well, then let's get into so the the the
the parts where I have the biggest
questions and I think and then you know
I would love for you to ask me and pick
my brain as much as you want but I think
this will lead to it is your um emphasis
on secret society's
uh Freemasons number numerology and this
kind of stuff. I I have to admit it's
not some I I find it not all that useful
even in making predictions or explaining
the world. Um, and I I'm curious
why you do. And I and I want to preface
that that I I don't think it plays no
role. Uh, as we as we get into maybe
this part of the conversation, I'll I'll
preface this by conspiracy theory.
Thinking or conspiracies is such a
flimsy term that I'm really not afraid
of. But I but I there's certain things
that don't kind of pass the smell test
for me of, you know, when it drifts over
into like why are we
deploying or pointing to secret
societies or or conspiracies or
Illuminati or whatever when just sort of
normal human psychology would be enough
to explain the the the situation at hand
of greed or whatever. So, uh, just give
me your sort of general sort of like
where does that emphasis come from on on
something like I I pulled up one of your
things. I think it was your post on when
World War you said World War II started
the day America attacked Iran, you know,
and you're writing sort of an assessment
on that very first day. It was when we
didn't even know if Kmeni was was dead.
But then you write, you know, um that
American officials have stated that
Operation Epic Fury will only be a 4 day
or will be a 4-day operation, which
means that it should end on Tuesday,
March 3rd, which coincides with the
Jewish holiday of Porum, when Israel
celebrates how Jews rally together to
foil an extremist plot or extermination
plot in ancient Persia and killed 75,000
of their enemies as recounted in the
book of Esther. That day also uh is when
a blood moon will appear and Freemasons
who control America's national security
apparatus rever the number 33 and it
goes on from there. It just feels like
at some point that paragraph shifted
into like wait why are we talking about
the Freemasons now? So so where does
that come from?
>> I completely sympathize and a year ago I
would have I I would have completely um
agreed with you that this is all just
silly conspiracy. So what happened what
happened was this. So when I started
this class um I was I wanted to
understand how the world worked and I
and I wanted to explore all different
possibilities. Uh that's how my mind
works. I'm very curious. I love to
learn. I love to ask questions. Um I
love to explore
>> and if you go back to my um early uh
lectures like the first two series uh
the first on geo strategy where I made
the prediction that the United States
would attack Iran. If you go to
civilization where I do where where I do
60 lectures on the history of human
civilization,
>> I do not discuss secret societies at
all. I don't discuss conspiracy theories
at all. But then there are certain
things that uh led me to think much more
about conspiracy and secret societies.
Um so I started to look more into 911
about um you know the moonlanding about
JFK.
um I started to uh look more about
what's happening uh in geopolitics and I
started to recognize that you know um
this standard geopolitical theory that I
have game theory doesn't really explain
everything because for me my question my
my question is why do these patterns
persist and who are the people who are
actually implementing these policies and
why are they doing this um So I had all
these questions in um my mind and so I
started to you know do research on the
internet which is a terrible terrible
way to like learn anything but I became
much more interested in different secret
societies the Freemasons uh 17 Frankus
the Mormons and like you know again like
I had a very standard classical
education where none of this was ever
discussed right I never heard the word
Freemasons before my life um before like
two years ago And so I started to dig
deeper and deeper and I started to read
more texts. Okay, so um I'm not sure if
you if you know who Albert Pike is, but
he is the grand architect of making
American Freemasons and he wrote a book
called Morals and Dogma and it's like a
thousand pages and it lays out
systematically the belief system of the
Freemasons. And you just read the book
and you apply it to what's been
happening in the 20th century in the
21st century, then you're like, "Oh,
this seems as though it's a schematic
for how to uh um move uh the political
system forward." And then and then uh I
read um Jacob Frank's um sayings uh um
wisdom of our Lord and you just read
what he writes and you you just think
think about how this world is turning
out. Well, then there's this connection.
And then um I started to do more
research on Isaac Newton and his
interest in alchemy and his interest in
biblical prophecy. And um you know, for
me, unless you look at this esquetology,
it's almost impossible to understand why
this war in the Middle East Middle East
is happening because it's it's it's a
complete dump dumpster fire, right?
Trump went in without a plan, without a
strategy, without a purpose. And now
he's just making stuff up as he goes
along, right? He's now he's saying that
our main purpose is to reopen the strip
of hummus to promote global commerce and
it's like sorry buddy but that thing
wasn't closed before now it's closed
because you started a war you killed
their grand you killed their so I mean
like I don't think people behave
irrationally I think there has to be um
a logical reason why this is happening
unless you factor in the esquetology and
the secret societies I think it's very
hard to explain what's going on So, so,
so you know, I'm doing I'm doing
everything as a thought experiment. I'm
doing everything as I'm curious as to
what's going on. Let's try different
possibilities and let's see what sticks
as opposed to like this rigorous
academic research which is like, you
know, like I've done 10 years on this
topic and here is my paper
>> and Right. So, so it's a complete
opposite of of academic scholarship.
>> Yeah. No, I think that's fair. Um yeah,
I let let me preface this um with uh
my my approach here because I I think we
are full of a lot of mythologies and a
lot of bad information. I think I think
it's kind of how we operate. We we get
as as children we get sort of a a
mythalized version. It's very
nationalistic and biased or religion
tells us something. Um and and I too
like you. So I I grew up a little my
background wasn't it was really boring
American you know apple pie background
Jewish background which I'm sure we're
going to talk about sort of Zionist u
but the suburbs of America played
baseball and you know I had friends and
I had a different childhood than yours
but I I did have a certain uh mythology
coming my way that I always was worried
about and it was it was this Zionist
Judaism post Holocaust American style
Judaism but in particular one of my sort
of founding
intellectual
uh moments that I I still recall. I was
in Hebrew school, which is like extra
school that I went to a little bit after
on Tuesdays and Thursdays. It must have
been like 14 years old or something. And
a lot of the education in that is
Holocaust based and World War II based.
It's it's the real bar mitzvah, frankly,
is is the birthright trip when you're 16
or 17. I didn't go on it. separate
story, but after you're 13, you start
getting a lot more of this. And the
mythology of Hitler and Nazism is very
strong. It's the founding myth, and it
does a lot of work obviously for the
support of Israel and the continued uh
sort of culture. But I remember my
teacher one day talking about Hitler and
describing him as a monster and using
the word monster a lot. And I remember
probably like you thinking like I'm not
very satisfied with the way this
conversation is going. And I raised my
hand and I basically said monsters don't
exist, right? Monsters are fairy tale
stories. My mythologically we could talk
about monsters, but Hitler was a man and
the Nazis were men and the IDF are are
are men or humans and so is Hamas and so
are you and me and everybody watching
this and humans are capable of doing
this. And and if we're going to walk
down the street with the mythology about
a monster and if that's what I have to
look out for of the next, you know,
twohorned devil walking down the street
to watch out for the next holocaust.
Well, I'm never going to see it because
monsters don't exist. So, I want to know
what really happened and why it
happened. Now,
>> pulling the the some people are very
worried about this. So, just to be
frank, when I when I told my audience
that you were going to come on, many
people were like, "Oh, don't talk to
that guy, right? He's he's super
dangerous." Um, and and they sent me
clips, which I'm going to ask you about,
of like, oh, he's a Holocaust denier and
all this kind of stuff, and I want you
to clarify them. But somewhere between
me as a 14-year-old being like, you
know, telling me that Hitler was a
monster and it's just a big evil and
anti-semitism is this, you know, ancient
devil that I have to always look out
for. somewhere between that being
and you know the Holocaust didn't happen
is obviously some truth that I want to
discover because I don't want any more
to happen and because as you said the
patterns keep repeating themselves and
we keep repeating themselves you know
that's how I approach a lot of these
questions and then just one more thing
to put on your plate because uh I I like
to question a lot of things as well and
I and I doubt the official story 911 I
was I was near New York and it became
Many people still doubt that story
obviously and it made a lot of people
conspiracy theorists but I had some
friends who I was very close with who
actually lost to suicide. Um when I
think they start one in particular I
tell a story on the show fell into a
certain kind of pattern of conspiracy
theory thinking that I don't think was
quite
>> attached to reality anymore. And he
started reading a lot of William Guy
Carr. I don't know if this is someone
you've come across. He's really big on
the number 33 and the Freemason stuff.
he was an anti-communist and so like
sometimes just to sort of push back on
like reading a lot of stuff certain
certain books can be as well
but anyway that's how I approach this
question so why don't we try to meet
somewhere in the middle I'm curious you
know we came from very very different
backgrounds on these questions but
clearly you and I are both dissatisfied
with a story about something
even as as monumental as did the
Holocaust happen or you know what was
Nazism about that I do want to find
truth about and I feel like we're
clearly not alone and it's why you're
getting so many views, but they are
careful conversations and I will admit
starting to pull the thread on that
sweater makes a lot of people very very
anxious. Right.
>> Right. So, one funny thing about me is
uh you never went to Israel, right? Have
you been to Israel?
>> I I did go to Israel. Just to complete
that story, I was uh you know most of my
friends went to Israel when they were 16
or 17 years old, which is not quite
birthright. you have a birthright to go
until you're 26 according to Sheldon
Alderson, but this was like paid for by
by more wealthy parents to send your
kids on like a fancy trip. My older
brother went on it. I opted out of it
because I just didn't want to go and I
hated it and I went to Africa instead
and it kind of changed my life. I tell
that story elsewhere on the show, but I
have gone twice including also to
Palestine on film projects which is
really my day job as a filmmaker. So,
yeah, I've been there twice. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right. Yeah. So, um I've been on the on
the on the Birthright trip. Um, so I'm
not Jewish as you can tell, but I've
been to on the Birthright trip. I I
spent a week in Israel. And the reason
why is that uh in 20 um in 2012, I was a
famous educator in uh in China. So the
technon invited me to visit uh Israel.
Um and I said, I'll I'll come if you let
my students come as well. So um they
they arranged for us to do the
birthright thing. So it's not
technically birthright but we stayed in
the same host went to the same locations
got the same tour guides we also had a
security guard um so so but but I mean
Israel is just lovely and uh you know on
the first day went to the Hoskov Museum
in Jerusalem I'm not sure if you've been
there but it is it is one of the best
museums in the world regardless of how
you feel about the content I mean it's
extremely welldesigned and um I mean and
the tour guide uh I mean she brought us
to tears I mean she So she was American,
but I mean she she was such a great
storyteller and she was very passionate
about her her job and that was one of
the most moving experiences of all my of
my life. So um you know I've always
believed in the standard Holocaust
narrative. Um and you know one of my
favorite books is actually Hannah Iran's
uh origins of to totterism. It's a
fantastic book here. Yeah. my in my
opinion really the best political
science book of the 20th century. Uh
it's something I taught before to my
students and it's such a powerful
brilliant uh book and that help me
understand the Holocaust a lot better
you know. Um so my issue is this my
issue is I believe the Holocaust
happened. So in so my opinion, Hitler
made a speech every single day demanding
the extermination of the Jews
>> and the Nazi bureaucracy spent uh years
and years planning this out
meticulously, right? Because I also read
Henry Ran's um benal of evil um in
Jerusalem. And so I so so I just assumed
in my head this was the case that it was
a systematic and bureaucratic um mission
to exterminate all Jews from from
Germany. And um so when I was teaching
my civilization course I wanted to show
uh the anatomy of hatred what drove the
Germans to hate the Jews this much. And
I wanted to analyze Hitler's speeches
and the bureaucratic memos in order to
gain insight into the psychology of
these Nazis because that's my
background. I'm an English literature
major. And um I specialize in close
reading. We call close reading at Yale.
Um so we basically read text and uh look
at diction and syntax in order to figure
out the psychology of the the writer.
And so when I was teaching my Germany
like like Prussia,
um I spent a lot of time looking for his
speeches, going for his speeches which
was not that many and I tried to do a
lot of research on the internet and I
couldn't find anything. I mean so so so
that's that's what confused me. It was
kind of dissonance where
>> if it is a systematic extermination
ordered by Hitler, you would think
there' be a speech justifying or
explaining why he's doing what he's
doing in order to rally the German
people to his cause. Or at the very
least, there would be a blueprint, a
bureaucratic blueprint for how you would
actually implement this. Because I mean,
it's logistics, right? You need to bring
in the gas from somewhere. You need to
pay for it. You need to Right. Right. I
mean like like like like like like it
has to be like a military operation and
I couldn't find any documentation. I
couldn't find any um real direct
evidence and that's why in my lecture um
I said listen um I'm not saying the
Holocaust didn't happen. It must have
happened but there's no direct evidence
for it that I could find which I found
really frustrating. Okay. So so that's a
background to what happened.
>> Yeah. Um, I I think that's still going
to not leave people satisfied because I,
you know, they're I'll tell you from
again my per my perspective, the the
mythology kind of always outruns the
truth and that leads to people then
questioning if the truth is the truth at
all. Most times I think the exaggeration
is just for political or psychological
reasons. So, for example, I mean, I, you
know, I grew up hearing about the
Holocaust a lot every day. And in my
mind, I, you know, you get the picture
of the striped pajamas and, uh, you
know, decimated body and the gas
chambers and the arbite mocked fry at
Awitz and you get this impression of
this, you know, massively mechanical
machine like a like a Pink Floyd video
or something. And you know the truth is
and you get the 6 million which and I
don't you know I'm not a historian but
it seems like by all historical accounts
the settled number is actually 5.2 to
5.4 whatever still like an insanely
massive number. I'm referencing like Roy
Kasag in my head for that one right now.
Um and to your point about numbers in
numerology six is a is a bit of a holy
number for Jews and the six day war was
actually five days and they like the
number six. So maybe that plays into the
mythology storytelling of it, right? Um,
but you know, a lot of they were killed
on the spot, shot, uh, you know,
murdered in trains, all kinds of
different ways, which is a different
picture. And that doesn't mean the hol
that is everything I just said is like,
of course, the Holocaust happened,
>> but like the mythology of it and kind of
the storytelling, the monster machinery
version of it, you know, is is
exaggerated. And so, you know, you said
you're an expert in or you study
language and everything. the language
becomes obviously incredibly like
delicate to parse those kinds of
questions. For example, it's very um I
think it's known that a lot of Zionist
groups uh very controversially and I
think disgracefully go out of their way
to not allow other victims of World War
II to be included in Holocaust memorials
and whatnot, the Roma and everything.
And I think it's despicable, but there's
political reasons for it, right? They
want to own that history in order to
justify their project in in Zionism. I
don't need like a sort of, you know, PhD
in psychology to know why they're doing
that. I just think it's horrible. But
then, you know, to say if I would say
like, you know, the the Jews were a
primary target of the Nazi
extermination, but basically the Nazi,
you know, Aryan mythology was interested
in exterminating all non-aran people,
like all enemies of the state. So Poles
who were like amongst the first victims
and homosexuals and Roma etc and Jews
were included amongst them. Um you know
is that me denying or downplaying the
Holocaust? It just all gets a little
crazy and overpoliticized. So uh but you
know with with what you said I just want
to be clear like you know there are
train records and there are gas chambers
that really existed and there obviously
are survivors with tattoos and whatnot.
Like there's evidence to a degree that
obviously something atrociously horrible
happened and Jews were amongst the
primary targets. And if that's not
enough for people to just be like that's
how things happen as humans, well then I
I can't really help them. If they call
me a Holocaust denier after saying that,
like I don't think anything will satisfy
them. But you know, is that Yeah, you
can respond to that because it's a very
very
>> subject and I think I think I completely
agree with you and I would also add in
this is war, right? and they they're
gonna have like food shortages and guess
what? They're not they're not gonna give
food to people that they don't like.
Right.
>> Right.
>> So, I mean, a lot of it's gonna be
starvation. A lot of it's going going to
be um uh criminal uh neglect. Um a lot
of it is just going to be um hatred of
other people. Um and and I I think that
is disgusting in itself.
>> Right. Right. Right. Well, that's great.
Well, then yeah. So then and to your
point actually this is a really good
almost stay on it and we could talk
about the Judaism thing because so when
you went to Israel and you did the
birthright stuff I think this is a
perfect example. I'm assuming they took
you to Msada as well. Did you do the
hike and the sunrise?
>> Yeah, it's a beautiful place and and you
know it's such a it's such a compelling
story. Um the tour guides we had were
fantastic. You know um Masada is is
definitely one of the defining moments
of Jewish history.
>> But they hate the Romans by the way.
they their hatred for the Romans was
palpable.
>> Yeah. But but but it's a perfect example
because so like this story uh and I
don't know if if you know it the story
around Msada so the mythology for the
people who don't know this it's this
fortress you know up in the up in the
mountains that um uh you climb every
birthright trip goes there basically and
you guys went there as well. They do
this sunrise experience. It's this
emotional kind of like punctuation mark.
George W. Bush went there immediately.
Donald Trump was supposed to go there on
his first trip ever to Israel, but he
but they wouldn't let him land a
helicopter there, so he crossed it off
the list because he didn't want to take
the thing to the top or whatever. But
it's a really important place. And the
mythology is this group of Jews who was
facing extermination. This is in second
temple Judaism. So second temple is
built in in Jerusalem and they're in the
middle of the Roman Jewish war where the
Romans are conquering Jerusalem in the
whole area. and and you know their
intent on wiping out the Jews and
extinguishing the Jews and this one
group of rebel Jews w was at this
fortress. They retreated there and they
realized it was a lost cause and the
Romans were closing in and they build
these mounds and they're going to be
taken but instead of being captured and
enslaved they commit an act of suicide
together like 900 of them or something
and they draw lots to see who gets
killed first and you know you kill the
next person and the very last person
kills himself. It's like this crazy
romantic story, but but that story is
almost certainly according to
the archaeologist. And so so you know
his name I forget his name. Yagdal Yadin
I think. So, but again this makes
perfect sense that he was uh Bengurian's
uh architect or archaeologist and he was
a state archaeologist basically and a
big Zionist and it was a fervor of a
mission to basically dig in the ground
everywhere in Palestine and and claim
that you found Jewish civilization to
make the claim to national sovereignty
even stronger for the Jews. Um and all
modern archaeologists people should look
this up. all modern most modern
archaeologists think like he basically
exaggerated the story and made this
whole story up. Yeah. Based on the
account of one guy who was a he was
actually Jewish and then he switched to
the Roman side, Flavius Josephus or
something. It wasn't his real name. He
switched to Roman name.
>> Yeah. So, if you know this original
story, um the original story was was
about the Sakari, which like they were
actually described almost like a
Hamas-like group, like an extremist
group who killed people and murdered
people and they were assassins. Um, and
so this historian of Jewish culture who
actually was then working for the Romans
described this this thing that happened
at Msada as as a mythology for the Roman
Empire. almost ironically to tell them
that you you weren't actually killing
Jews. You were just killing extremists.
You don't have anything against the
Jews, but you had to take care of these
extremists, which sounds identical to
the way that Israelis talk about or the
IDF talks about their war not with
Muslims or Islam, but with these
extremists in Hamas, etc. So, anyway,
the MSAs the Msada story is a perfect
encapsulation. And by the way, for
anyone who's who's interested, the IDF
still goes there when they complete
their mission and they and they and
their new recruits and they say Msada
will never fall again. It's like this
very strong mythical.
>> So saying all that though, it's like I
didn't need to
smuggle in any kind of conspiracy
weirdness. It's like I understand all of
the pieces of that mythology. Um, but
obviously it's it's to your point of how
you predict history uh or try to predict
history using this stuff. Those beliefs,
those myths are incredibly operative in
our world. And making a prediction about
something like, you know, will they uh
blow up Alaska mosque in Jerusalem? You
need to know this stuff in order to do
it. So I don't know if you want to
respond to that but that's a perfect
example for me of like conspiracy
mythology but actually just you know
look
>> hijacking history right
>> so yeah so we were in Israel for a week
and the Masada experience was definitely
one of the highlights because the story
behind it was so compelling right where
>> the Roman Empire had surrounded the the
Zealots right the the the last defenders
of of of of the Jewish faith and the
Romans were brutal like they tried
months and months to take it and they
were like catapulting dead Jewish bodies
into Msada knowing that the Jews could
not, you know, like like the Jews would
would protect these bodies and therefore
they they would get diseases, right? So,
it was a really compelling story that
was very black and white and you know,
which which I mean like it just sticks
in your mind like I I went there like in
2012 and it was just a very small part
of our experience, but I it was still
one of the most memorable experiences
along with the the Holocaust Museum. So
regardless of how we feel about Israel,
they have a really great way of doing
propaganda uh and uh narrative. That's
that's so powerful.
>> Yeah. Yeah. His his father, just as a
side note, uh that archaeologist was the
one who discovered the Dead Sea Scrolls
as well. So he was he was already sort
of in this lineage of archaeologists. Uh
but yeah, but that yeah, calling it
propaganda, I think, is the proper way
to put it. And then it's um yeah when
people like you and I start uh
questioning it I think or especially you
you get a lot of push back from you know
those on the internet who want to uh you
know discredit you as it were. But so so
I guess I'll ask the question then. How
does how does all of this kind of
knowledge help you or do you think it
helps you make predictions about the
general trends of of the world? You
know, leaning on the Illuminati and all
of these kinds of things. I mean, how
how I guess I guess I'm still a little
stuck on the secret societies. Like how
real
>> do you think that is? Or are you using
it as sort of just a predictive tool? I
just need to know that.
>> Okay. Um, so I think that esquetology is
interesting for my work because if you
actually think about what esquetology
is, it's almost like a hidden history
because human history goes back, you
know, thousands of years. And if you
actually look at history from a broad
perspective, there are certain patterns
to it. And the reality is the lavant,
the Middle East has been um a the site
of many important wars just because of
its location, right? Because the lavant
controls access to Egypt, Anatolia,
Mesopotamia, and this historically was
the wealthiest part of the world. So
there there's always been these wars
going on in the lavant. And I think that
um the like like if you live in the
Leavon, it's almost like you're living
through the apocalypse every you know 20
years or 40 years because there's so
much violence going on. I think that
this esquetology is it's almost a way of
trying to allegorize this traumatic
history in a way that future generations
can learn from. And that and that's why
I think you know like like it's like if
you want to predict World War II the
best place to I mean you can just bet
it's it's going to be in the Levant or
Middle East because historically that's
always been the case right? Uh because
because of of of
a very important location. So I think
first of all esquetology is important
because um it's revealing to us certain
patterns of history. Um that's that that
is then formulated into an allegory.
That's number one. Number two is I see
history almost almost as a plan or a
script, right? Because if you really
believe in this estology, then you also
want to achieve it, right? I mean like
it's almost like when you grew up uh as
a child and you you watch this movie,
right? And you love this movie, right?
Star Wars movie, right? Well, you want
to be Luke Skywalker, right? You want
you want actually if you have the means,
if you have the power, you want to be
like Luke Skywalker. You you look like
like Jeff Bezos, right? What what's he
doing? He's shooting like rockets up in
the space because he was a huge Star
Trek fan, right? So if you have the
power and the means you want to achieve
these childhood fantasies of yours and
so I think that's why esquetology is
also very important because the people
who run this world um even though uh we
don't know who they are, it seems as
though they do believe in this
esquetology. So that's the uh second
point um I will make and the third point
that I that I I will make is that
esquetology what makes it really
important um and uh in in our world is
that it's it's a generational script
meaning different generations can
achieve different aspects of this plan
and they can work towards the larger
goal um and and yeah so so that's why I
think esquetology is very important.
>> Yeah. No, that that was good. if I could
respond to it because because again the
one phrasing when you're like the people
who run this world and we don't know who
they are like you know it sets off
little flags for me where again I just
have flashbacks to like my friend who's
like well why did why did that have to
be in the explanation where I'm like
>> um let's talk about 911 right like you
know I think and people are starting to
ask serious questions about it from
Tucker Carlson and everyone else and
they should be I've been asking serious
questions my my whole life about it so
doubting the in quotes official
I think everyone should be doing at this
point. Um, and then talk about something
like Israel, right? Like Israel had a
had a um geopolitical advantage to that
day happening. Now, does that mean they
engineered it? Right? A lot comes down
to the verb you choose here, right? It's
like, does that mean they orchestrated
it? Does that mean they assisted it?
Does that mean they looked the other way
at certain times in hopes that it would
happen? And I think though like parsing
the kinds of careful words in there for
me has always been important because and
I'll just put this out there. If it was
I'll just take you literally and I and I
know this might be unfair to you but if
there were like a group of people
running the world and we don't know who
they are and they took that sort of
literally it would be like well if
Israel fully was orchestrating that they
never would have had it be a bunch of
Saudi hijackers. they would have had
have been like maybe an Iranian and a
Palestinian and a few other people that
they would have hated. Um, you know,
they would have changed some details on
that day to make it better fit the
narrative that they were then hoping to
deploy. Right? If Donald Rumsfeld was
fully in control of it, he would have
been like, "Can we make them all Iraqi?
Can we just, you know, can we do
something like that?" So, you know, the
fact that it it was like
close enough for them to try to fit this
narrative into the world and then, you
know, say Axis of Evil and and start of
world war, whatever, you know, they're
up to, I think is like somewhere in that
I always fall short of the kind of
sentences that you deploy of like
there's there's a group of people, we
don't know who they are versus there's
definitely
things that We don't know. We're not
told as the public that are
at play in even a big traumatic world
event like 911 that fall well short of
like complete control and pulling the
strings and people in a shadowy room and
the Illuminati deciding what's going to
happen on 911 but need need to be
exposed. And I and if I could just put
out sort of my hypothesis of your, you
know, extreme popularity is is because
everyone is sick and tired of being lied
to. And so they're certainly excited
about you offering, in my view,
sometimes an overly confident
description of what might be happening.
But people are certainly asking
questions and want want to know what's
out there. if you know like the the
Frank Church committee where America has
been in this mode before and he's like
people are sick and tired of secret
societies and he mentioned Israel by
name uh and certainly like we're we're
in that mode again. So yeah, I don't
know if you want to respond to that but
it's just still that language of like
how literally am I supposed to take when
you say people running this world we
don't know who they are. I'm kind of
like, we kind of know who they are and
we're tired of them kind of pulling the
strings a little bit, but they're not
like, you know, flying chemtrails over
and dropping brain control, you know,
serum into my mind. That's just like
there's some there's somewhere where I
have to find my footing in that,
>> right? So, um I'm still grappling with
secret societies, like who they are,
what they do. Um, and but I mean if you
go to the Epstein files, right? Um, for
the longest time people just assumed
this guy was a Mossad agent and he was
running a honeypot operation. They
actually look at the Epsom files. It was
clear from these exchanges that the
Epstein Island was like like a weekend
getaway for him. This is not what he was
doing. I mean like like like Epstein
Island was just fun and Bill Gates and
Bill Clinton went because it was fun.
But his main business was money
laundering, arms trafficking, uh
geopolitics,
um and remember we would have have
actually about 50% of his emails and and
people say it's actually only 2% of of
his emails.
>> So how he made his money, what he was
doing around 911, we don't know. Um how
he's involved in geopolitics, we can
suspect. Um and actually um some hackers
have released ehoot bracks emails and
those emails give us more insight into
how Epson was um really entangled in
geopolitics. And again this this is a
guy who has no official position who I
mean no one knows who who this guy was.
And I think the great mistake was to
assume that he was working for Israel.
uh you're actually better off saying
that Israel was working for him, right?
So, it's almost like nation these nation
states, Israel, United States, Russia,
they're all puppets of people behind the
curtain, this transnational elite. We
don't know who they are, uh but they're
they're actually the ones who are really
pulling the the strings and and the term
I often use to describe these people is
like transnational capital, right? city
of London, Wall Street, these people and
what allows them to coordinate, what
allows them to actually control the
world is uh the control of secret
societies, Freemasons, um Jesuits, uh 17
Franks, and so this is my working theory
of how the world works without any
evidence, right? So, so, so this is all
speculation on my part.
>> Yeah, that's fair. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So,
it's not my preferred language of the
secret societies or whatnot, but you
said something actually I didn't address
in the previous answer about esquetology
that I think is really really good um
about sort of the the habit maybe a
psychological habit to um you know
assume the role and play the part that
fulfills these holy books and whatever
it is. I think that is a real true
phenomena which again doesn't you know I
don't think that you need to deploy the
secret society stuff to do it. um like
famous Jeffrey Epstein, you know, I just
talked to Peter Binard who's an
interesting guy and we talked about
Judaism quite a bit and he I I think
some of my audience was happy with it.
Some thought he was deflecting a little
bit where
>> I probably like you absolutely think the
doctrines matter what these things say,
right? That and so I I made a film with
Sam Harris famously don't like what he's
done with the conversation at all. I
think he's made massive mistakes. I feel
like the new Sam Harris, but I'm going
to do it without being a bigot if I can.
um where I'm putting on the table that
yes, religion actually matters and it
and it affects world events. It affects
the way you operate in the world and
mostly I think it operates as a kind of
scaffolding or molding um function of
existential anxiety or resentment you
feel or dread you feel. I had Dashi on
the show who I really love wrote a book
about Islamism and its sort of uh
marriage with anti-imperial
anti-American capitalism and how it
became a vessel to fight that. It makes
people very uncomfortable to talk about
something like Hamas as a resistance
movement. But, and I'm not excusing the
religiosity of Hamas, but of course, if
the Palestinians had all been Janus
Buddhists or something and experienced
the same kind of um suffering and
humiliation and cultural humiliation for
for years, for decades and decades and
decades, they would have a lot of
resentment, which I think would still
surface, but it would surface in a
different way given a different
religious context. And that is not to to
be a critic of Islam. I'm actually
saying it has very little to do with the
initial sort of feeling of injustice.
Judaism is is its own set of
theocracies, esquetologies,
uh religious beliefs. It's a it's a
complicated one. And I think it has
unique features which I could talk about
or I could put my thoughts out which
absolutely shape the way that it kind of
manifests and appears in the world. So
someone like Jeffrey Epstein had the
Talmud sitting behind him in uh in in
his I was going to call it Epstein
Island but using his name. I don't know
how much he read the thing. He basically
seemed illiterate based on this, but I
think he probably wanted to somehow live
out a fantasy of being a Jewish whatever
rabbi or conqueror or whatever.
Netanyahu clearly sort of gets
enraptured by these same kind of
fantasies. He envisions himself as the
next King David or Herod or whatever.
He's talking about Genghaskhan now. So
these things really really do matter and
become the kind of lens through which we
operate our violence many many times in
the world and I don't think Judaism is
different. So you know do I think it
works in a way that you know Jeffrey
Epstein is reading the Talmud and it
tells him to do something and then he
goes and does it? No. Again, I don't
even know if you could even read the
thing, but I think that stuff does have
an absolutely crucial role to play in in
not just the personal that I'm talking
about with someone like Jeffrey, but the
geopolitical, but the the conquering
stuff. So, uh that's where I find your
lens really useful. And if I will just
put this sort of pin on it too because
imagine if you know human civilization
was sort of wiped out in a massive war
right now and everyone just sort of was
crushed and then all of this was left as
rubble and buried under millennia of
dirt and whatever and then some alien
civilization came along and found all of
our ruins and the archaeology maybe even
some hard drives that they could figure
out how to plug back in and they wanted
to retell the story of what happened
here. I think they would absolutely be
telling a story about the third temple
and these beliefs about gods and demons
and you know the same exact way that we
talk about when you go to archaeology
museum ancient civilizations and all we
hear about is they had some belief in a
certain god and these people had a
belief in you know the great spirit and
they fought over they thought this
volcano was god well I think if we
actually had a time machine and went
back there we'd probably find humans
just like you and me who were making
arguments about like well it's geopolic
politics and psychology, but the thing
that kind of sticks in the ground for
millennia as you're saying or future
generations is kind of the gods and
demons stuff. And so, and so I so I do
find your lens actually quite good for
for predictions. I think we will live
through the day when Israel blows up
Alaska mosque. Uh, and how else would
you explain that other than doctrines of
Judaism? So, it matters.
>> Yeah. No, I completely agree. uh and
it's something this is a re this was a
revelation to me like uh late in my life
like two years ago because I had a very
classical education uh and and what what
what an elite education does is it
educates you out of religion right uh
and it teaches you to think in a certain
way that is non-religious and the
reality is that most of humans are
religious like you know 80% of humans
have practiced one religion they take it
very very seriously and it's what gives
them meaning and purpose in Okay. One
thing I will add to your summary which
which was brilliant um is that there's a
possibility that
um humans have have been on this planet
for at least 200,000 years doing
civilization. Okay. So we know from
science that humans uh go back 200,000
years but we only have like 10,000 years
of our history right back to go play
tepe. And so were we what we what were
we doing for the rest of rest rest of
this time? It's hard for me to believe
that we're doing nothing all this time.
So it's it's entirely possible that
we've had different civilizations
before, right? So if you go to
Antarctica, uh if you go to Amazon, if
you go to Copepe, if you go to the Grand
Canyon, you'll see a lot of evidence for
lost civilizations. And I think you're
absolutely right in that what religion
really is, it is a dissolation, a memory
of these lost civilizations because u I
mean like the idea of religion is is the
easiest to um uh survive u time and
space. So so so that's why I think
religion is so crucial. And if you look
at all the major religions, they're
basically saying the same thing. And if
you go deep into the occult, it goes
back to a very similar outlook in in the
world. So recently I've been studying
the cabala. Um and you know you know I'm
not sure if you have if you have any
experience with the cabala but it's
really interesting
>> and I can completely understand how if
you're immersed in the cabala
it drives you into certain behavior
um that manifests in in in the world uh
in the world today.
>> Yeah I'll I'll share. Yeah, that's quite
good. I I can't speak on the ancient
civilization stuff. It's fun to think
about you maybe you know more than I do
about what's in the dirt but um I'm open
to it. Um when I'll tell you my sort of
experience with Judaism. Uh because you
know I grew up again American suburbs
post Holocaust. Parents were born in 51
both of them. So this is after the
creation of the state of Israel. Uh but
you know grandparents certainly with
living memory of of Europe and World War
II. Uh my particular family chain left
earlier in the early 1900s.
But so I grew up with the Judaism that
we all learned Hebrew, but we only
learned how to pronounce it. We don't
know what it means. So we're all sitting
there in the synagogue mumbling in a
language that we've memorized the sounds
of, but we have no idea what it means.
There is an English translation on the
other side, which I would always read
because like you, I'm like, "What the
heck are we saying? And does this
matter?" And so I think for someone like
me, I got broad strokes of the religion
mostly passed down through family and
custom and you know uh holidays and
whatnot. But you you get the emphasis of
the religion and Judaism is a
particularly interesting one that I
think has its own potential forms of
maladies the same way that Islam,
Christianity and they all do. And in
particular, it's it has an emphasis on
there's a lot of ways to interpret this
on being a family. Uh which could be a
genetic line, which could be sort of a
national line. It's a biblical story. So
re interestingly, and maybe you know
more than I do on this, but with
Judaism, it's kind of weird that in the
it has a creation myth just like all the
others and it's the Garden of Eden. It's
Adam and Eve, but Judaism doesn't exist
at the beginning of creation. It's a
very strange thing the way that other in
I think I think unique to Judaism where
you know all humans were created by God
and there they are and they're living
their their their life and at some point
God gets really annoyed and with his
creation and decides I'm going to
destroy it all. I I hate these people.
Sends the giant flood and then this one
guy named Noah's like hey it was sort of
ironic. He's like I have faith in you.
So it was this different flip of things.
I have faith in you. I'm gonna survive
this thing and I'm gonna keep a bunch of
animals. Maybe like a just in case. Like
just in case you change your mind. And
after this great flood, God changes his
mind. He's like, "You know what?
Actually, this guy's right. I promise
I'll never do this again." And he and as
a child, you learn about like this
rainbow and a dove that comes out. It's
like a nice story that he finds land and
everything. And it's this promise that
God isn't going to destroy the world
again. You're good. You're safe now. Um
and you you had faith in me. So now in
you're you're the chosen people. And
it's almost in an ironic way of like you
chose me and so now you're safe. And so
the the descendants the the sons of Noah
really is the line of Jews. And this is
where Judaism starts. Some, you know,
there's other tellings that Abraham's
the first Jew or whatever, but that line
becomes Judaism. The sons of Adam, which
were the original humans, still exist,
but they're not sons of Noah. And so
when you read things like the Talmud,
it's a very strange. Written 1500 years
ago, rabbis arguing about legal
applications of things like, you know,
if if if a woman is really a virgin on
her wedding night because she's worth a
different amount of money if you divorce
her, like these intricate whatever legal
arguments. How do you prove if someone's
a virgin? But you'll that's where this
word comes from and all this kind of
stuff. And there's another passage going
around that, oh, they don't treat
non-Jews like humans, they treat them
like animals. Well, I kind of just gave
you the theological reason. It's that
well, you know, they're still creatures
of God, but they're not descendants of
Noah. And in in the most like lovely
interpretation of this, which maybe my
mother wanted me to get, it's like,
well, you're you're a Jew and you have
this family and this lineage and it's
ancient and you're protected and you
could always find each other on Earth.
But that's also a very tribal kind of
like the flip side of that is that it's
kind of separate but equal which has a
very dark history as a term in in
American racism. And so all that is to
say that our conversation here about why
religion matters and how it might show
up in the world is a lot of work
including myself has been done on trying
to strip Zionism away from Judaism. And
I think in some ways it's slightly
disingenuous because what I just told
you would be like, well, it's totally
understandable how you might get
something like Zionism as a special
covenant. You know, oh, we don't hate
the Arabs, but this is our land. God
promised us this land out of Judaism.
And of course, there's going to be
theologians who disagree with me and are
going to be chiming in being, and I'm
not a scholar, but I think that kind of
stuff matters uh in the world. So
anyway, that's my experience with
Judaism on a personal level. I don't get
a lot out of it. I'm not a religious
person. I consider myself pretty
strongly atheistic. Maybe it was
educated out of me in a deep way, like
you said. Um, but I absolutely
am interested and curious in the way
that these things show up in the world.
And I don't want to shy away from
singling out different religions as
different possible dangers in the world.
And so, yeah, if you're going to explain
World War II, you better understand that
story about Jews, especially if you
think it's going to start in Jerusalem
because people take it very seriously,
>> right? Yeah. So, um obviously there are
like thousands and thousands of variants
um of of Judaism,
>> but but but let let me um let me go into
two pretty extreme variants
>> um to structure the conversation. So um
there are um certain Jews who believe
that actually the real founder of
Judaism is Jacob uh because Jacob is the
founder of of Israel
>> and Jacob Jacob had a brother Esau
>> and they are enemies of each other. So
in their understanding um the this
doesn't the the sons of Jacob will
always be at war with the sons of Esau
and Esau is interpreted to mean Rome
that line is gives birth to Rome and
Jacob's line gives birth to um Israel
and that and and that's why Rome had to
destroy the Jews because of this
historical animosity and but what this
also tells us is that um this war
continues because Western Europe up the
angles are descendants of Rome and the
Jews are descendants of of of Israel. So
So that's one extreme variant that I
think there are certain people in Israel
who do believe. Okay. So um now I want
to go into the Cabala because um you
know it doesn't I know I know less about
this one just to put that put out out
there. I didn't really was never really
exposed to it. I know Madonna was into
it. That's about it.
>> Yeah. Okay. So I think cabala is really
important if if if we are to understand
the modern modern state of of Israel.
Okay. So the idea of cabala is this um
there is the Torah. The Torah um um is I
mean it's written down but these are all
stories and these are our allegorories
and you know rabbis have been struggle
struggling to how to best interpret uh
these stories. And so what the cabala is
doing is it's taking hermetic philosophy
um and then applying it to the
allegorories in order to interpret the
Bible at a cosmic level. All right. So
um let let me give you an example of
this. Okay. So the first story of course
is a story of Adam and Eve. And the big
question is like why do they eat that
fruit when God told them don't do that?
You're in paradise. You've got it. You
you're you've got it all good. Just
don't do one thing man. don't eat that
stupid fruit and you're good. And they
still
>> ate that fruit, you know, and now
they're banned from paradise.
>> And so that's a story, right? So what
Cabala does is that it takes that story
and then um and it renders it at a
cosmic level. Okay? So uh in in the
Cabala uh it um version, Adam um is the
first being created by God. Okay? Adam
Kadm. Okay. And why what does God create
um Adam Kadm? Because God is the will to
bestow. God is all generous, allloving,
all forgiving. But if you're the will to
bestow, you need a force to bestow it
onto. Right? So what God does is God
contracts and creates Adam Kenmmont,
which becomes the will to receive.
Right? God's the will to bestow. Um Adam
Kenmont is the will to uh receive. The
problem with this dynamic though is that
the will to receive implies that you are
you are egotistical. You see things
selfishly, right? And that's how you're
able to receive. But if you see things
selfishly, egotistically, you can't
appreciate the generosity of God, right?
It's it's almost like, you know, I
invite you to my house, you know, and
I'm really happy that you're coming to
my house, so I cook you this elaborate
meal, 10 course banquet, like the like
the the greatest food you'll ever have.
And you come into my house, and you're
embarrassed because you're like, "Wait a
minute here. What is going on? Why is
there all this sumptious food in like
like does he want money from me? Does he
want me to like, you know, give me his
dog? G give me like like you know give
me his daughter what like you get
confused by this right and so you you
have to reject this generosity and
that's what Adaman is right is the will
to receive cannot appreciate the full
generosity of God so he breaks apart
okay and then um Adam breaks into like
6,000 or 600,000 roots or divine roots
or whatever okay and anyway I I don't go
specifics but but the but if it's the
beginning then the purpose of life is to
re to come together with God. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> To reunite with God, a reunion of God.
Okay. It's almost like the um like the
dynamic of um thesis, antiis symphysis,
right? And that's the very purpose of
life to come back to God. The question
then is like how do you do that? Well,
if you look at the Bible, there is a
model or or a example of how to do this
and that's King David, right? King David
was not a great conqueror. what he was
was a flawed person who you know had sex
with Bashiba and to disguise the fact
that Bashiba was pregnant he had the
husband Uriah the height killed right
and then what happened was that God sent
a sent a prophet Nathan to tell him you
know do you recognize you're wrong and
David's like not really and so Bashiba's
child dies and then David is thrown into
months and months of immense mourning
repentance um repentance
and redemption. And at when that
happens, what what's really interesting
is that that brings them closer to God,
right? Constant prayer
>> and and and and so for these cabalists,
that's what they think like what
salvation is. Salvation is to recognize
your failings, your limitations in order
to seek forgiveness from God. When you
do that, when you open your heart to
God, you become re reunited with God,
right? because now you are the will to
receive and God is the will to bestow
and that's the end of history. Okay. So
let the cabalist interpretation why this
is problematic is if you look at the
modern state of Israel there are certain
religious fanatics who believe that if
we drive the world to insanity right if
we cause the end of the world where
Israel is threatened all Jews will come
together and recognize their spiritual
limitations and like King David before
him seek forgiveness from God and when
when their heart really opens to God,
okay? When they are fully contrite, when
they when they seek to repent fully,
then God will forgive them. But first,
Jews have to do that, right? And that's
why they're creating so much conflict in
the Middle East.
>> So, so yeah. So, yeah. I mean, yeah.
>> No, that was that that was excellent. I
mean, yeah, I never heard that that
Cabala is story, but it um it aligns. So
my my favorite thinker and writer is
Eric from I don't know if you've spent
time with his books but he wrote the
escape from freedom and and it's my
favorite one uh art of loving and many
more but he was a turning point for me
to Eric from philosophies and writings
for me were were instrumental to
understand this um
existential fear that we actually have
of of freedom which I would equate to
everything you just said as as what God
might bestow upon us and all of the ways
we hijack ourselves to get rid of that
freedom, to run from that freedom, to
flee from that freedom. And I don't
think this needs to be anything extreme.
If anybody has ever just wished to be a
bird or an animal, I think it's a desire
to just be like, can I just stop
thinking about morality and what's the
next best thing to do because it's
driving me crazy. The simplicity of it,
I think, you know, it leads to fascism
and all kinds of other in all kinds of
other ways. But in so many ways, I I
think what what we are seeing, and it's
not just unique to Jews, but
a rejection of existence itself that we
have a kind of deep
hatred of existence or we feel like we
don't we haven't earned it which is an
interesting thing that we just don't
actually you know uh can't accept God's
gift of existence or whatever and we
have a death wish and those people are
going to bring us all down with their
death wish which is like I always tell
this to my wife and she's like I don't
and I'm like yeah but they're going to
they're going to burn bring you down
with them because they're going to light
the whole world on on fire with this and
So I I think that that's uh it's a it's
an interesting story and it's a crucial
story. Obviously the Christian Zionism
has gotten involved directly into this.
Um so your critics I'm going to go back
to your critics and kind of the way you
think is I want to ask a question about
sort of the
consequential or utilitarian
uh necessity of these myths. Right? So
even something like the Holocaust,
right? Famously the one that probably
you get in the most trouble for is like,
well, even if the story is not entirely
true that we're telling the children
about it, this myth is actually like a
good myth to to promote because because
if we start pulling back on the truth of
it, we're just going to create a whole
bunch of neo-Nazis and a whole bunch of
angry people and we're going to just
kill everyone again. Like this is a
total hypothetical. I I'll choose a
different country because I would get in
trouble with YouTube probably. But like
if we discover 911 was actually like if
you had the information that 911 was
actually a full inside job and it was
like one mastermind sitting somewhere
doing it and whatever you could say he's
in Israel or everything. But if I told
you, if I ran like a perfect simulation
of the universe and I said, if you've
released that information, even though
it's true, you will cause, you know,
massive killing and everyone will tear
down the governments and we're going to,
you know, hundreds of millions of people
die. There's lots of people who would
say, you know, it's it's better just to
keep this as a myth and not reveal the
truth of this thing. Um, you know,
because the consequences of telling the
truth or or us losing this myth are just
too great. or even something like Msada.
Like I said, I think that is a myth that
does incredible harm in the world,
promoting that myth and continuing
propaganda. Uh but there's potentially
I'm I'm potentially full of a ton of
historical myths that are of no
consequence if I believe them or not,
but there might be some that are. I
don't know. The moon landing one is one
you mentioned which I, you know, I don't
really have strong feelings about. I
think it was real, but I don't I haven't
really gone gone into it much. I saw the
Fox thing. you know, if there's
definitive proof that that was faked,
would that change anything about the way
we are? So, I don't know. I want to ask
you like a philosophical question about
truth and the consequences of it. Like,
you know, you're pulling out a whole lot
of myths on your show and pointing to a
whole lot of myths. Like, how important
are these things? Do you think the
consequences
might outweigh you, I don't know,
talking talking about a certain issue
that people just think is too dangerous
to touch?
>> Yeah. No, that's a really good question.
And this is something that I've
struggled with all my life because um
ever since I was young, I was I've
always been a curious person. And I
think like like the truth um is value in
itself. Um and if
and and I think it's your individual
responsibility to seek the truth.
Whether or not you choose to broadcast
this or not um is up to you. But I think
it's everyone's responsibility to seek
the truth. um where you can you know um
you know I've become very interested in
religion and one religion that has
always fascinated me is uh narcissism
like like the gnostics
>> and the gnostics believe like the path
to salvation the path to god is through
truth seeeking through through knowledge
and that's something that I sympathize
with where ultimately
>> we don't know why we're here ultimately
we have to um think about why we're here
and what brings us happiness. And all my
life, one thing that's really brought me
happiness or basically enable me to
sleep well at night is truth seeeking. I
I mean like I don't want to um brag or
anything, but like I I feel that's why
I've committed my entire life to truth
seeeking. Right? Right. So, I first
started out as a journalist and I was um
going around China trying to interview
normal people trying to figure out how
this country really works. And I I I got
a lot of trouble with this. I ran into
mafia people. I was arrested by police.
I got deported. Um and then when I
worked for United Nations, it was
actually my first well-paying job. And
I'm not sure if you know the UN system,
but it is like the cushiest job in the
world cuz you literally sit in the
office every single day. You collect a
fat big paycheck. and in 20 years time
you retire to like a full pension. Uh
your your kids go to national schools.
It's really the best job in the world.
But I was in Afghanistan and um there
are certain things about the United
Nations that really disturbed me. So
there was one instance instance where
aven flu was being reported in
Afghanistan. I I was I was ordered by my
boss to um report that aan flew had come
of Afghanistan and I told him I can't do
that because if I if I were to do that
every Afghan would kill his or her
chicken and and then they would they
basically starve. I mean like why would
you do that you know like like think
about where we are and like the reason
why he wanted to do that is because he
wanted funding for to tackle aven flu in
Afghanistan and so I I I had to quit my
job because I could not eat sleep if if
if I ever went out and said you know
like avian flu is a problem Afghanistan
when it's not a problem I'll tell you
what what the problem is malnutrition is
a problem Afghanistan okay
>> uh um you know your birds being sick
it's not a huge problem. So, um, and
then I started to work in study abroad
education and I first went into this
field helping Chinese students apply to
American universities because I thought
this was a pathway to promoting
creativity and critical thinking skills
in China because I assumed that to get
into the Ivy League, you needed to have
to possess strong English. You need to
have a love of books. You need to have a
very curious mind. And it turns out
that's not actually true. if you happen
to be the son or daughter of the guy who
runs this country, they'll let you in as
well. And so I became very disenchanted
uh very disillusioned and I quit that
because I didn't want it because it was
a huge business. It was a huge scam and
I didn't want to be part of that. And
for years and years I just wandered
around trying to trying to do teacher
training, trying to promote curriculum
reform. And there's actually no interest
in that. I mean, um, but but I I didn't
I didn't want to,
um, um, you know, sell out. And then I
met my my wife who changed my life. I
mean, I I I mean, like, I met her um 10
years ago and I I hit rock bottom
because I was unemployed. I didn't have
any money. Um, I was fat, I was a drunk,
um, I I was really depressed, I was
suicidal. And then I met her and she was
like an angel who came to save me. I
mean like I really believe that the
universe saw that I was in despair and
she and the universe sent an angel to to
save me. Um and and
>> we had a child and that child was also
an angel. Um and I'm like I said to my
wife, listen, this is this is silly. I I
mean like I'm trying to promote
education reform. I'm trying to fight
for the truth. I'm trying to promote
goodness in the world, but we're poor
and we have a kid to support. So maybe I
should write recommend recommendation
letters for people to get into Yale. You
know, that's a million dollars like
right there if I if I'm able to get a
kid into Yale, right? And she said, "No,
what's important is to be a good role
model for our for for our child. Uh
what's important is to be true to
yourself." And um that's you know and
and and like I knew then that like I I I
I was really I had found an angel. Um
and being with her has really convinced
me that truth seeeking is the highest
good in this world. Regardless of what
happens be true to yourself. Like if
other people are lying and you know it's
a lie don't don't I mean like like don't
repeat the lie. I mean like
>> you have to speak the truth and and and
and and so that might be naive but but
but I but but that's a principle why I
live by.
>> Yeah. Now that that that was quite
beautiful that the story in Afghanistan
was a perfect example but just to be
clear on it was was it true that there
was aven flu there or he it was actually
he was asking you to lie so he could
benefit. Is that
>> I think I think I think there were a
couple cases of aven flu but I mean like
who cares man there's mult nutrition in
the country right you're asking whole
chickens
>> come on man
>> yeah yeah but but so but to to push on
that analogy though I mean that was an
instance where
you thought the truth would do more more
damage consequentially by sharing it
with the world or maybe you just
couldn't figure out a way to express
that truth in a that wouldn't result in,
you know, a hysteria of killing
chickens. And I I just want I just want
to be fair to to your critics. I run
into this, too. I don't think this is
particularly a professor Xiang problem.
I think we all face this issue,
especially those of us who are, you
know, people don't like that I ask my
guests, why are there Jews in the
Epstein files? And my reasoning for it,
my reasoning for it is this, I think,
the same as yours because of truth. So
as just like a quick aside, you know,
when I started my public work, I'm a
documentary filmmaker. I live on the
line between truthtelling and
storytelling, right? I understand the
mythmaking. I'm not a journalist who are
maybe trying to tell the truth. I'm a
I'm a I'm a mythmaker that uses the
truth in documentary filmm. But the but
you know, I jumped into a lot of this
work after 911 when expressions by
George W. Bush particularly to to the
world when everybody was very
emotionally raw was this has nothing to
do with Islam. And I thought that's
disingenuous. I know what he means
certainly he thinks you know
he's maybe his good intentions is like
don't go blame your Muslim neighbor for
this. But I thought it would backfire
that it would be, you know, Joe Schmo in
Idaho is watching Fox News and he's
like, "Man, he says it has nothing to do
with Islam, but like they're all
shouting Alahu Akbar, reading the Quran,
and they're all Muslims who flew into
that plane and you know, what am I
supposed to think of this?" And what I
was afraid of was the backlash and
hysteria around that guy picks up a
knife and go kills his Muslim neighbor
who had nothing to do with this, etc.
And so my initial jump into these things
and again this was more in the the Sam
Harris universe who again I I think has
just massively fumbled and maybe out of
other reasons made a mess of that. Um
but I think the intentions was how do we
tell the truth about what just happened
on 911 or since World War II in the
Middle East with what's happened in the
Arab world and their hatred for America.
How do we tell the truth about that
without confusing people and saying
something I think as well-intentioned
but false as this has nothing to do with
Islam? And now I'm in the same boat with
Judaism and what's happening in
Palestine, Judaism and Zionism, Judaism
and things. People, it makes people very
uncomfortable to talk about these
things. But I
to to my critics, I would say I think
it's disingenuous to say it has nothing
to do with Judaism. These people are
just freaks. Because Joe Schmo in Idaho
sees that all those Israelis that he
might begin hating for taking his tax
money and using it to kill Palestinians,
you know, or doing these things at the
synagogue he doesn't understand, he's
going to go kill my brother in Allentown
or in Pennsylvania because he's a Jew
who has nothing to do with this. So my
fear is the same of like how do we
express these very delicate truths in
the world in a in a way that doesn't you
know um lead to bigotry. I know you get
accused of this by like Medi Hassan or
whatever of just like paring right-wing
conspiracies. How do we walk this tight
rope? I have to admit some of your
language is in my mind falls off the
tightroppe but I this conversation has
been really helpful for me to understand
why you're trying to walk that tight
rope. Um, but yeah, I'll give you the
final word on sort of continuing to try
to walk that and then, you know,
addressing people who are are worried
that you you you fall off too much or
you're you're just, you know, you're
just going to inflame people who wish to
do harm.
>> Yeah. So, I go to a time in the 1990s
when open free debate was a core liberal
value. So, I might say things that
offend you and you might say things that
offend me. So what we do is not call the
police on each other. What we we we
don't cancel each other. What we do is
we sit down together like what we're
doing right now and have a honest good
faith conversation about our different
viewpoints. And this leads to mutual
understanding. So So I mean I I I don't
know what happened because before if
people just disagreed you you would have
a conversation and figure out you know
where where the differences were. And
now nowadays it's just like we cancel
each other. It's like I refuse to
platform you because I disagree with you
or I call you names because I don't like
you. Uh whereas before you know um
people were really serious about
thinking deeply about the other
perspective and trying to reconcile um
the differences and that's that that's
why the world is falling apart, right?
Because like you look at America where
it's so polarized that I think like 9%
of Republicans will refuse to date a
Democrat and vice versa. So something
like that. I like I don't know the
statistics but it's something ridiculous
like that.
>> Yeah. It's stronger than religion. It's
it's it's it's like the biggest marker
for that. Um yeah I I I totally hear
that and I cosign that. I think instead
of saying offensive some people are
worried of what you're saying is somehow
dangerous. But when you ask you don't
know what happened. I think what
happened and this is maybe me agreeing
with you really strongly is that the the
the propagandists of the world the
mythmakers of the world mostly in the
west their mythology is just getting too
ridiculous. Epstein was of course a huge
reason a huge you know pin in that
bubble but even just from a moral
perspective people finally seeing the
face of Palestinians maybe a generation
that was able to learn English so you
can understand them better. you're like,
"Oh, they're human that they're
killing." So, morally, a lot of people
are like, "Hey, if this genocide on my
phone is necessary for me to live this
comfortable life in Ohio, I'm out. I
don't want this." The mythology is no
good anymore. We're not the good guys
that you told us we were. So all a lot
of their mythologies I mean even down to
the specifics of you know people
doubting Charlie Kirk or the
investigation and all you know or Renee
Good or Prey like the stories the
storytellers
of the west have gotten so ridiculous
that I think what has happened is for a
long time the mythology maybe you can
think of like 1950s America with that's
what people idealize in America the the
myth believing the myth of you know what
they told you on your nightly news kept
you safe. Most people I think were happy
to live in that little bubble even if
they knew it was probably a myth. They
were okay with that world. That world
doesn't feel safe anymore. They don't
believe that myth believing the nightly
news is keeping them safe anymore
because certainly their economy is you
know people can tell you the economy is
fine but people are buying groceries. So
the myth has started to crumble in such
a way that people one don't believe it
keeps you safe anymore to believe it and
two it's just gotten so ridiculous that
believing it just stretches the creduli
I mean the MAGA movement the Trumpers it
was
solely based on never doing what he did
in Iran and then he did it anyway even
MAGA MAGA people who are sickopantic are
being stretched to their logical limit
of how much are you going to believe
this myth is keeping you safe and then
what comes next is question everything
and then okay I I can agree that that
world from some very nervous person is
potentially more dangerous and more
chaotic and you're going to have I'm I'm
down for that but I I don't put the
blame on people like you and me asking
questions about it. I put the blame on
the myth makers just got way too absurd
with with this thing and the deal
believing their myth didn't keep people
safe and comfortable or even happy
anymore which is something we didn't
talk a lot about it. you know, Elon
Musk, the richest man on earth, I think,
is miserable. So, we can see it doesn't
even make you happy playing the game.
So, I'll let you have the final word,
but I think this is a cool place to to
land the plane.
>> No, I completely agree. Um, and I really
enjoyed this conversation, so thanks so
much for hosting me, Jay.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, but yeah, no, I mean, I feel as
though that the entire world has become
much more bureaucratic. Um, and it's
really about the elite using bureaucracy
to maintain their hold over people.
And it's making everyone miserable, you
know, especially in Canada where where
where I I grew up, like the bureaucracy
is just absolutely ridiculous.
>> You know, they're passing like these um
speech laws that govern speech. So now,
you know, like like if you um commit a
crime, you're less likely to uh be
approached by the police than if you
were to post uh the fact that crime has
been committed. Uh and the reason why is
that in a bureaucratic environment uh
people are lazy, people are complacent,
people just want to do the easiest thing
possible. So it's much easier to go
arrest a compliant person than it is to
actually go deal with an actual
criminal. And so the absurdity, the sort
of um complacency of the world that we
live in. Um and so people are seeking
relief and and I think that like for
people people want actual answers.
People want to hear alternate voices and
people want a larger story of what's
going on. Um, and just like the idea of
shut and obey doesn't work anymore. And
I I and I I agree with you and that this
is a positive trend and I think that
like you know um we're headed humanity I
think is heading to a really rough time
but at the same time it's going to cause
a spiritual awakening among people. So
I'm very hopeful about humanity as a
whole.
>> Yeah, I'm with you on that. So we'll
leave it on that hopeful note. That's
really nice. Um, well, this was really a
pleasure. I wasn't sure what to expect
because you're such a strange anomaly
and phenomena online, but it was really
really a pleasure to to talk to you and
get to hear a little bit about how you
think. So, uh, who whoever you are out
there in China that the internet is so
confused about, uh, this was really fun.
>> Yep.
>> So, I obviously love that conversation.
I have some final thoughts here on sort
of the the Professor Xiang phenomenon.
Uh, first off, uh, I think I have to
issue an apology to Canada. Not sure
exactly what the jab was to Canada in
there, but uh to my Canadian viewers, um
sorry about that little that jab coming
from him. I got a sort of a kick out of
it, though. Um and second of all, I
think uh uh you know, the the Professor
Xiang phenomena, I think you heard, you
know, he's not some sort of like
mastermind researcher who's doing
anything that you and I can't do. Uh
he's an interesting guy asking
interesting questions and putting things
together as best he can and broadcasting
them. And then in some ways I I think
the popularity if it's if it's authentic
these these massive numbers he gets on
YouTube let's assume it is um the
popularity of it I think points to some
sort of maybe desire or hunch of of uh
that we kind of all wish we kind of had
a high school teacher who was a little
bit more like him perhaps or willing to
talk about the things that he talks
about rather than I don't know open your
history book to page 34 to read a you
know a story about Saka Jia and
some like white man's fantasy of
Louiswis and Clark or something or I
don't know let's talk about how great
Winston Churchill is for an hour and not
talk about the the massive racism and
and and Zionism that he promoted etc.
Like I think I think most people high
school students to everyone who who went
to high school can recognize that
they're they're they're fed up to a
degree with knowing they're getting just
shoveled a load of state propaganda
Um, and then this guy,
Professor Xiang, comes along, at least
on the internet, and is at least willing
to talk to you about like, hey, there's
something totally different going on
that explains the world, whether or not
he's sniffing, you know, down the right
path all the time. Uh, you know, which I
I don't think he always is. Um, there
there's certainly something to that. I
mean, I can imagine if he put out all of
these same kind of theories just, you
know, in a basement talking to a camera
or in front of a a yellow curtain like
he likes to do, uh, I don't think they
would have really caught anything. But
there's something about the whiteboard
and a classroom that is is tapping into
our our probably like near global
distaste and and annoyance at our uh
education, what we got fed to us. And
and so, you know, I think there there's
really something to that behind that.
one one thing that he did say, you know,
obviously I I I don't share his kind of
uh rush to secret societies and maybe
even esquelogy totally to explain things
like he said a line like you to explain
the war in Iran which makes no sense to
him. Um you need these theories to kind
of explain it. Uh you know I think
they're helpful and I think they help
explain actually specific things that
might happen. for example, you know, if
Alakamas blows up, you better understand
the esquetology uh and biblical stories
about why that particular event happened
and why it's so important. But I think
you can probably explain something like
the war in Iran using uh you know my
preferred lenses of of of a leftist
critique of imperialism maybe neoc
colonialism. Someone I referenced on the
show a million timesqwame and Kruma from
1965 laid this out for us uh in a postw
World War II Africa about this new form
of economic colonialism that was was was
replacing the overt colonialism preworld
war II. You know, I think you
understanding things like the petro
dollar and the American debt and dollar
dominance could probably get you all the
way there to explain, you know, why this
war is happening. And you don't need to
totally fold in some of the, you know,
different theories about people pulling
the strings behind uh, you know, behind
a a curtain somewhere. U, but they don't
they're not mutually exclus exclusive.
You can certainly do all of those
together, but I think it would be nice
to see uh Professor Xiang uh entertain
and work in more not just standard
geopolitics, but my preferred lens of a
sort of leftist anti-imperialism. Um
that explains a lot of the world we're
in today without without having to lean
on things like the illum Illuminati and
I think fairly flimsy uh notions of
secret societies. But so and then on
that topic of secret societies, I you
know I mentioned the Dead Sea Scrolls
and I wanted to pick it up here. I think
the story of Msada is a super important
one that that we told in there and how
propaganda works and and probably this
is not unique to Israel, although I
think it's uh just
massively ex on steroids in a place like
Israel and Zionism. this fervent idea of
trying to create national myths and
ethnic myths and biblical myths in order
to to promote this project. And people
who claim that there's a unique or
unfair or even anti-semitic focus on a
on a country or a project like Israel
when you know half the world is colonial
sort of projects um I think are are
really ridiculous. I think they're
completely missing the the unique
insanity of a place like Israel that's
tapping into these 2,000 3,000y old kind
of stories and sort of to try to to to
implant literally in the ground national
myths which in the Msada case I when you
if you look it up really is complete
So I didn't give all the
details on the story with Jiang, but you
know the myth is like 900 something
people commit this suicide in in the
fortress but actually the archaeologists
only found like 10 skeletons there. It
doesn't match at all. There's pottery
shards with names on it and of course
they were interpreted as being this like
pulling lots in this very romantic idea.
It sounds like a Shakespearean play of
people killing themselves, which is
completely sort of Roman Roman theater,
which is why it is the way it is. Um,
but there's there's no evidence that
that pottery was some sort of weird
suicide game. Um, this was all just sort
of a a fantasy and and made sense to
build this kind of national myth when
you're trying to promote a project like
Zionism. But I mentioned in passing his
father u was an archaeologist who uh and
I say the word discovered uh was was the
archaeologist responsible for for sort
of announcing the discovery of the Dead
Sea Scrolls. And if I tell you the story
of the Dead Sea Scrolls, you'll find it
immediately fishy and you'll be
suspicious of it. So the story is almost
again too romantic and too good to be
true. It's like a Bedawin goat farmer in
Kuman, which is in modernday West Bank.
In like 1946, so we're right after World
War II ended and right before we're
going to get an is Israel state created.
Um, a goat gets lost and wanders into a
cave. And the Bedawin goat uh herder is
looking for for his goat. and he gets to
this cave and he he takes a stone and he
throws it into the cave to try to see if
the goat's in there and he hears pottery
break somewhere in the cave. And then
he, you know, wanders in maybe with a
torch or something like imagining
Indiana Jones here and discovers these,
you know, the these
pillars, these these these pottery vases
and inside these old scrolls that are
that are rolled up and he and discovers
this thing and this archaeologist, his
name was Eleazar Suk Sukenik who is the
father of Yaga Yadin, the one who came
up with the Masada story. Suknnik
is the archaeologist that that takes
these things out and pieces them
together and they're found in like 10 or
11 caves or something. And these become
known as the Dead Sea Scrolls. They have
Hebrew written on them and Aramaic
written on them. And there's like
passages from the Torah in them that
are, you know, near direct. It's like
the earliest copies we have of these
things as well as a bunch of other
teachings. It is is sort of thought to
come from this sect of Judaism called
the Asen. Asenesis. I can never
pronounce it, but there was like four
sects of Judaism at the time. And if
this story sounds fishy to you, it's
when this miraculous discovery of proof
that ancient, you know, that Jews from
the first to 3rd century BC were there
in the area and practicing some form of
early protojudaism.
um you know to seems to to be a little
too convenient to give claim to this
national project in 1947 that's about to
be announced to the world and claim that
this is Jews reclaiming the land that
they were at 2,000 years ago. It's like
some claim of indigenousness. If that
all sounds really fishy to you and way
too convenient, well, of course it does
to me too. But what are what are people
like you and I to do who are not
archaeologists are not experts other
than to just remain skeptical. And when
we hear the Mada story, I refer to
archaeologists who are like, "Yeah, that
seems to be total bullshit." Um, just
sort of a project of national
mythmaking, a very powerful one. But the
Dead Sea Scrolls apparently have been
carbon dated to match that time between
the first and third century. And you
know, they seem to be authentic and
everyone says they're authentic. And
what am I to do? What are you to do?
What are we all to do? At some point,
there's this layer of trust in these
kinds of institutions, right? If you
doubt it, I suppose you just have to
think there's some sort of conspiracy or
cover up about the carbon dating or the
organization doing it or whatever. And
feel free to look into that stuff.
That's really not my bag. If James Lee
is watching, it sounds like something he
would love to do. So, go at it. Um, but
you know, on its face, it sounds
incredibly fishy. And I think it goes
without saying there's no moral argument
or rational argument that even if the
Dead Sea Scrolls are legitimate and in
authentic and, you know, there was some
early tribes of Jews that were in the
area. I don't think there's anything we
didn't know. It has no bearing for me on
an ethical or moral, legal, political,
any kind of claim to the land to reclaim
it 2,000 years later. I think that stuff
is absurd and anyone who makes that case
um is just is a bozo. But it's
interesting history nonetheless. And so
now we're in this world I think where
back to the phenomenon of Professor
Xiang where I think a lot of people are
just realizing that we've been fed a lot
of We've been hijacked through
historical propaganda to a to a
significant degree. We, as I put forward
in our conversation, the myths of
believing that stuff no longer are
keeping us safe, no longer are, you
know, keeping us wellfed or or happy
even. And so, we're beginning to
question them and question everything. I
don't know how we tiptoe our way through
truth in this world uh of sort of
questioning everything. I think
remaining skeptical certainly of the
media that that seems to be done but
skeptical of mainstream sources
skeptical of history books but also
remain skeptical of the people or ideas
that doubt the official narrative. Um I
don't know how exactly we're going to do
that but uh I don't think we have any
choice. If you think that's a dangerous
world where people are questioning
everything, I don't disagree with you as
I said, but uh we're here now. And so I
think let's um I don't know, do our
best. And if you are still watching at
this late uh moment, I think I deserve a
like and subscribe. So please do that.
And if you're really interested in
helping the channel, I do have a
membership program, which is a couple b
bucks a month to join. Um and as a as a
bonus, if you join it, I do a monthly
hangout on Zoom for the members. There's
a members only hangout uh on the last
Sunday of every month at noon Eastern
and it's super fun. So if you're
watching this late, you might be
interested uh in joining that. We could
discuss certainly this interview and
upcoming things in the world and um
yeah, I appreciate the support and uh
that's it for me and my interview with
Professor Xiang. So take care everyone.